رحت من الملاحظات على البرنامج كانت انه
برنامج الحكومه لدعم شركات الحكومه فاغلب
الشركات شركات حكوميه 100% او بنسبه عظمى
حنا عندنا في البرنامج كثير شركات يعني
مملوك القطاع الخاص بشكل كامل ولا فيها
ايه ملكيه انا برنامج استثماري اللي يهمني
تكون مساهمه مدرجه
وانها تستثمر
المليار ريال او اكثر امثله من الشركات
القطاع الخاص اللي اخذت هذا الدعم
[موسيقى]
هذا سقراط من اذاعه ثمانيه هو انا عمر
الجريثي استضيف قاده التحول وقاده الاعمال
وقاده الراي وسولف معهم مع المستجدات رؤيه
السعوديه 2030 ضيف حلقتنا اليوم هو معالي
الاستاذ عبد العزيز العريفي الرئيس
التنفيذي لبرنامج الشراكه مع القطاع الخاص
شريك البرنامج هذا اعلن عنه في 2021 وظلت
بعدها فتره كذا صمت
وفي الاسبوع الماضي تم الاعلان بشكل يعني
كبير عن المجموعه الاولى من الشركات
المستفيده من برنامج الشريك وش فكره
هالبرنامج وش الغرض من تاسيسه
مين هذه الشركات وليش هي اللي دخلت لهذا
البرنامج هل لازم يكونون كلهم شركات
مملوكه او الحكومه مستثمره فيها ولا ممكن
تكون في شركات خارج الحكومه ضمن برنامج
شريك ايش نوع الحوافز اللي تقدم لهذه
الشركات
كم الهدف
90 لتحقيق من استثمارات خلال العشر سنوات
القادمه الى 2030 او اقل من عشر سنوات
وكذلك سولفنا مع ضيفنا على السيناريوهات
المختلفه بمعنى لو التزمنا بدعم شركه
معينه
ولكنه لم تلتزم بالاستثمار كيف يتم
التعامل مع هذه الحالات هل لازم الشركات
المدعومه
تتوقف عن توزيع ارباح وش اشكال الدعم
المختلفه اللي يقدمونها وغيرها من نقاط
اترككم مع الحوار حياك الله ابو محمد
شرفتنا نورتنا الله يحييك ابو عبد الرحمن
انا بروح للوراء شوي وبقول عطنا اهم
ذكرياتك في ستانفورد
يعني اليوم السعوديه صار عنده برنامج
ابتعاف بس انه مختلف ما عاد في الابتعاث
لاي مكان صار التركيز اليوم على افضل 100
جامعه الظاهره او 200 جامعه
وش اللي يفرق في هذا النوع من الجامعات عن
بقيه الجامعات ليش صار التركيز على
هالجامعات
فنعتقد ماستر فيها انا اخذت انبيائي طبعا
الجامعات هذي يمكن يعني
اصعب شيء للقبول يعني انا كان سته في
المئه من المتقدمين يقبلونهم بالبرنامج
فانت لما تروح يعني قاعد تتعامل مع شريحه
معينه
ناس كلهم حققوا نجاحات وفي نفس الوقت عندك
يعني افضل
الكفاءات من ناحيه التدريس وحتى من ناحيه
ممارسين
فهذه يمكن بشكل عام يعني
مميزات العامه وبعد ما تدخل هل الصعوبه
تستمر ولا هي صعوبه القبول بس لا طبعا في
ضغط كبير يعني انا اذكر لما كان مطلوب منا
اننا نخلص مئه ساعه في السنتين كانوا
يضغطونك 60 ساعه في السنه الاولى اساس انك
تواجه الضغط فاذا وبعدين يعني
نفس الشيء كان عندهم
انه نسب يعني درجات يجب ان يكون فيها كيرف
فاقل عشره في المئه من الكلاس ياخذون دي
ولازم انك يعني تحافظ على معدل معين فما
كانت بالطريقه يعني
فكان في ضغط لكن بعد السنه الاولى تتضح
المعالم وتدري انك يعني ان شاء الله متوجه
متوجه فتبدا تستمتع في التجربه اكثر ولو
في اليوم كذا شباب في مقتبل العمر قاعدين
يسمعوننا وش اهم توصيه تعطيهم اياها لو
كان عندهم طموح انهم يقبلون في افضل
الجامعات على مستوى العالم وش اهم الاشياء
من اليوم انا اعتقد انك يجب تنظر كيف تقدر
تميز نفسك وخبرتك وتجاربك بحيث ان تكون
مميزه لان في الاف الناس تقدم كيف تقدر
انك تميز نفسك عنهم
والجماعات هذه تنظر الى طبعا التحصيل من
ناحيه
التحصيل الوظيفي لكن ايضا الاشياء اللي
خارجه عن الوظيفه يعني سواء مبادرات
غير ربحيه
مشاركه مجتمعيه جوانب مختلفه تبني يعني
سيره ذاتيه لك تكون متميزه
وحسيت من المجموعه اللي كانوا معاك انه هل
فعلا عندهم قدرات مختلفه ولا هو اجتهاد
بمعنى هل لانهم اذكى مخلوقين اذكى ولا
لانهم كانوا يبذلون جهد اكثر من غيرهم مش
اللي حسم هلا المجموعات اللي قبلت في
الجامعات اعتقد طبعا يعني في عده معطيات
الاول طبعا القدرات اللي موجوده عندهم
الجانب الثاني اعتقد في جهد كبير يعني في
مسيرتهم الوظيفيه
او حتى في الجوانب اللي خارج الوظيفه فانا
اعتقد ان الجهد يعتبر عامل كبير في هذا
الجانب وكيف انك تقدر يعني ترسم
خبره لك مميزات تفرق يعني او تميزك عن
الاخرين
وبعد
المرحله هذه انت
عملت في قطاع الخاص في اماكن مختلفه ومن
اخرها يمكن جدوى كنت رئيس تنفيذ الماليه
في جدوى صح صحيح واحده من من يعني اهم
شركات الوساطه الماليه وبعدين انتقلت
الحكومه وش الفرق بين العمل والقطاع الخاص
والعمل الحكومه والله شف انا يعني
يمكن كان الانتقال كنت اعتقد انه عمليه
التحول والتغيير اسهل في القطاع الخاص جدا
صعبه في القطاع الحكومي لكن
اللي تفاجات فيه لا يعني
تقدر تسوي تحاول تقدر تسوي تغيير خصوصا مع
يعني
مرحله هذه مع الرؤيه والتحول
وصراحه يعني
فتره بسيطه يعني قدرت اشوف تغيير لما يكون
في وضوح وانت تبذل الجهد والجميع يشوف انك
الجهد وتكون في قياده وطريق واضح بعد
الجميع بالنسبه له اسهل فانا يمكن اقارنها
يعني
يعني الضغط بالنسبه لي في القطاع الحكومي
اكثر من القطاع الخاص عجيب هذا الحين اللي
قاعدين تعيشون انتم هذا اللي انا عشته
يعني اتكلم لك على تجربتي الشخصيه انا
بالنسبه لي تجربتي الشخصيه تعلمت منك اني
ما عاد افصح عن اسراري ههه لاي شخص قبل ما
يصير مسؤول لانه تذكرت سالفه الباص كنا
الحديث على يعني ايام جدوى عن بعض
الكواليس تصوير الحلقات وتوزيع المخاطر
بين المحاور وبين الضيف وكشفت لك اشياء
واجد يعني بعدها باسابيع قليله انضميت
للعمل الحكومي ورجعت يعني احاول اني اكسفك
ضيفلك
اوراقي مكشوفه
لين يسر الله الحين اننا يعني نكسبك كقائد
لبرنامج شريك انت رئيس التنفيذي البرنامج
شريك
من سبتمبر 2021
على
البرنامج في اكتوبر
2021 والبرنامج اطلق فيه مارس 21 فالح
اليوم يعني متزامنه مع حدث مهم اللي
قاعدين الان تعلنون عنا بخصوص البرنامج
الاتفاقيات اللي صارت فيه فاتوقع عند
الناس فضول كبير جدا من اللحظه الاولى
والان زاد الفضول لمعرفه وشه شريك وش
فكرته وكيف كانت بدايته صحيح برنامج شريك
طبعا فكره اسمه سيدي من البدايه وهي مبنيه
على انه القطاع الخاص له دور كبير ومحرك
رئيسي
للاقتصاد المحلي وانت طبعا يعني عمري يمكن
اكثر واحد متابع للرؤيه لما يعني رؤيه
ثلاث محاور رئيسيه اللي هي يعني
مجتمع حيوي اقتصاد مزدهر
ووطن طموح
فالجانب اللي حنا يعني طبعا وضعت المحاور
الرئيسيه ثم فصلت في يعني
الخطوات والبرامج والمبادرات وخارطه
الطريق
ولو نظرنا الى جانب يعني
اللي هو اقتصاد مستهر في عده مستهدفات
البرنامج ينظر الى الرئيسيه من ضمن هذه
المستهدفات اللي هي وصول المملكه لاكبر 15
اقتصاد في عام 2030 وايضا مساهمه القطاع
الخاص من الناتج المحلي بنسبه 65%
واليوم يعني يمكن الفكره الرئيسيه انك
تعظيم قيمه هذه الشركات
بانها يكون لها
تعظم قيمتها من ناحيه الاستثمارات انت
اليوم في اي طبيعه
لو ما تستثمر القيمه بتكون ثابته لما تضع
استثمارات
هذه باذن الله ان كانت ناجحه بتعظم من
القيمه
وبتزيد منها وفي تجارب صراحه يعني في من
عده دول سواء يعني تجربه كوريا اللي هي
بنيت على قال لك انا ابغى اكون دوله مصدره
وش اللي شي يميزني على العالم اني عندي
عماله اسعارها منافسه او رخيصه فلما جاء
نظر كان اقدر اصدر الصناعات الثقيله اللي
هي مبنيه على العماله فيكون عندي ميزه
تنافسيه
لذلك الدوله شكلت مجلس تخطيط اقتصادي في
الستينات وصار هو يرسم خارطه الطريق ويعطي
الدعم
مخصص الدعم يعني اكبر الشركات
اللي موجوده هنا
وهذا ساهم يعني في فتره الثمانيات
التسعينات صار نمو المحلي للبلد في
ثمانيه في الميه بشكل سنوي اليوم البرنامج
يطمح في
تكوين هذه القيمه تكوين هذا الاثر على
الاقتصاد فاليوم برنامج شريك
يركز على هذه الفئه من الشركات بغض النظر
عن قطاعاتها يستهدف استثمارات نبغى هذه
الشركات تصل الاستثمارات الى خمسه ترليون
ريال خلال عام 2030 وهذا نابع من
الاستراتيجيه الوطنيه للاستثمار اللي حددت
مبالغ الاستثمار المطلوبه ومصادرها
ويمكن برضو يعني الجانب الثاني ليوضح
اهميه الشركات الكبرى اننا لما ننظر يعني
الى اكبر الشركات او اكبر 10% من شركات من
ناحيه المبيعات او الايرادات
تشكل 80% من الارباح فهي اللي عندها في
القدره الاستثماريه لتحقيق هذا الهدف ولما
اقول خمسه ترليون فاحنا نتكلم على متوسط
600 مليار سنويا يعني احنا الان 23 باقي
خمس سنوات
على حدود 600 مليار سنويا لاستثمار صحيح
الى اي مدى الرقم هذا
شاطح والقابل التحقيق والطموح بزياده ايش
رايك شوف حنا يمكن يعني تعرف الرؤيه طموحه
وفي كثير من الجوانب بضعه ارقام كانت يعني
اعتقد انها صعبه التحقيق وان شاء الله
تحققت قبل يعني اوقاتها موعدها فاليومين
بلا شك فيه المستثمر طموح لكن في نفس
الوقت محفز لاننا قسمنا هذا المستهدف الى
جزئيتين اليوم انا عندي جزئيه استثمارات
اعتياديه الشركات بتستثمر طبيعه الحال
جاها حوافز ولا دعم هي ماشيه في هالخطه
وهذه اخذتوا المتوسط حق الفتره الماضيه صح
الصح وعندي استثمارات اضافيه هذه اللي انا
ابغى احفزها واجيبها اللي هي في وجهه
نظرنا انها خارج الاقتصاد
فهذه لما اجيبها انا يمكن المنظور اهم
منظور بالنسبه لي طبعا البرنامج تهدف
استثمارات داخل المملكه استثمارات محليه
لان تطمحي الى عائد اقتصادي ويكون له
مضاعف اقتصادي
اكبر من الواحد بمعنى اذا الشركه
على الاقتصاد ريالين ولا ريالين وربع بحيث
انه يحقق عده مستهدفات عندك محتوى محلي
دعم صناعات اخرى عندك تصدير زي ما تكلمنا
على تجربه الكوريه كيف انها يعني مكنت
عندك تحقيق وظائف بشكل مباشر او غير مباشر
فهذه الجوانب هي اللي تعكس
المضاعف الاقتصادي وزينت الان لما تيجي
تشوف اذا شركه تبني مصنع تستثمر مئه مليون
مئه مليون هذه بتجيب مقاول بتجيب موردين
موردين بيجيبوا موردين اخرين تحركت العجله
في لها فتره البناء بعدها وظفت ناس بتتحقق
داخل بدايه تشتري من يعني مواد اوليه
ومواد كذا واتحركت العجله ونفس الشيء صرت
تنتج انت شيء قد يدخل في انتاج مصنع اخر
وتحركت سلاسل يعني القيمه قبل ما ادخل ابو
محمد في بالضبط كيف يشتغل برنامج لسه انا
ابغى افهم اكثر وين موقعه في الحكومه انتم
انتم برنامج من برامج تحقيق رؤيه الحين
برنامج شريك بس ما انتم احد برامج تحقيق
الرؤيه اللي هي اللي تحت الرايه مباشره
شوف البرامج اللي تحت الرؤيه مباشره
حنا طبعا تحت اللجنه الاستراتيجيه طبعا
يمكنك هيكله
في لجنه استثمارات شركات الكبرى هذه راسها
سمو سيدي
تحت اللجنه الاستراتيجيه وهي المشرفه على
برنامج شريك
رئيس مين في اعضاء جميع اصحاب المعالي
المعنيين المعالي
ياسر رميان هو امين اللجنه ورئيس اللجنه
التنفيذيه فهو اللي مسؤول يعني عن
البرنامج بشكل
[موسيقى]
جميع يعني اصحاب المعالي المعالي وزير
الماليه معالي وزير الاستثمار مع الوزير
الاقتصاد معالي وزير موارد البشريه معالي
امين اللجنه الاستراتيجيه
ومعالي وزير السياحه هو ايضا
لمعالي وزير الاتصالات هذول الاعضاء
اللجنه وفي سؤال هنا تذكر طرح بكثره وقت
الاعلان وش فرق البرنامج هذا عن لجنه
تيسير عن شغلات الاستثمار يعني هل قاعدين
نعقد الموضوع ونكبر البروقراطيه بطريقه
معطله ليش ما الجهات هذه اللي تسوي الشغل
هذا طبعا شوف يعني اعتقد سؤال مهم
واليوم احنا دور برنامج مكمل لانك انت قلت
ابغى برنامج معني في الشركات الكبرى فانا
تركيزي كله على الشركات الكبرى
يعني لما نتكلم على وزاره الاستثمار يعني
معالي وزير الاستثمار في جميع اللجان وفرق
العمل يعني نعمل بشكل مقرب معهم وفي
تقاطعات كبيره فاليوم هي عمليه التركيز
ولما ننظر الى يعني الامثله او تجارب
الناجحه انا قلت لك يعني في كوريا شكلوا
مجلس
التخطيط الاقتصادي
وهذا المجكل في الستينات وفي عام 94 تم
محله انتفت الحاجه منه ومتى نفس الشيء
اللي انا شفت تايوان وقصه نجاحهم في
اشباه الموصلات
من الستينات شكلوا معهد ابحاث هو قائد
هالفوره كلها وخطط لها ويعني وكان ياخذ
الحوافز من الحكومه ويعمل حتى جزء كبير من
الشركات اللي اليوم تعتبر عملاقه انبثقت
منه فاليوم في حاجه يعني
التركيز وانه يكون في برنامج مخصص معني
بالشركات الكبرى ولما اقول شركات الكبرى
طبعا حنا شركات الكبرى عرفناها
انها شركات التي لديها القدره انها تستثمر
مليار ريال او اكثر بشكل سنوي طبعا اول ما
بدا البرنامج كان مليارين او عشرين مليار
وتم تخفيضه لضم الشريحه اكبر
الجانب الثاني بمليار سنويا او عشره مليار
الى عشرين ثلاثين صحيح الجانب الثاني ايضا
يجب ان الشركه تكون مساهمه مدرجه او
ملتزمه في الطرح خلال فتره معينه ليش وش
علاقتكم في هذا الشيء ناشف يعني البرنامج
اول شيء لما ننظر اذا شرط الادراج اعتقد
في جانبين رئيسيه استمراريه الشركه
واستدامتها لما تكون مساهمه مدرجه ومن
ناحيه حوكمه الجانب الثاني انها يعني
يكون فيها مساهمين يعني اللي الجميع يقدر
يستثمر في هذه الشركات اللي
صحيح جميل هذا يعني ما دام انه في حوافز
ودعم فحلو انه يكون لبقيه المجتمع
والمواطنين وعموم الناس
عداله في
الاستقرار في الشركه او او فعل كيان
ودي الحين ادخل اكثر ابو محمد على كيف
حددته هذا الشركات هل هم اللي تواصلوا
معاكم ولا انتو تواصلتوا معاهم لما لما
يصير الحديث هل انتم اللي تقولوا لهم هذه
حوافزنا واللي هم يطلبونها ودي افهم شلون
تصير العلاقه بينكم طبعا شوف العلاقه فيها
عده خطوات لما البرنامج كان في شركات ضمه
بعدين قال لي 24 صحيح بعدين طبعا اليوم
عندنا 28 شركه في شركات يعني
[موسيقى]
لما وظيفته في شركات ما قدرت انها يعني
لا تتوافق مع المعايير او الشروط او ما هي
مؤهله
فحنا الاجراءات اللي نسويها عندنا نموذج
الاستثماراتك من الان الى 2030 هذه الخطوه
الاولى الخطوه الثانيه حنا نجي ننظر الى
قوامك الماليه اصولك القروض اللي عندك
قدره الاقتراب وهل فعلا عندك الامكانيه
اليوم انك تستثمر المتطلبات هذه اذا والله
ما كانت القدره او يعني يتضح لنا نقعد مع
الشركه ونقول هذه ملاحظاتنا كيف تقدر
تستثمر هالجوانب لانه البرنامج يعنى
بالشركات الكبرى اللي عندها قدره انها
تستثمر وحلما بلا شك فيه حريصين على اكبر
قدر ممكن
يتوافق مع او مؤهل هذا الجانب اذا ما
كانوا يقدرون حنا يعني عندنا في البيانات
جميع الشركات وكمل قدره الاستثماريه
السنويه حقتها لانه لو جاء جميع الشركات
اللي في السوق لا احنا شركات اللي قدمت
على البرنامج طبعا
تقدم عليه عندنا فريق كامل يعني بالعلاقات
مع الشركات نعمل
عمل على متطلبات البرنامج
فعندنا خطوات
كثيره الاستقطاب الشركات انها تكون جزء من
البرنامج وهذا هو اهم شيء لانه اذا بنحقق
المستهدف معناتها يجب ان قاعده الشركات
تكون اكبر اساسا تقدر تستثمر يعني بشكل
اكبر
[موسيقى]
من تطور البناء الى اناقه التصميم ورفاهيه
الخدمات مع تميز الموقع حلول سكنيه مبتكره
ومستدامه مع شركه صفاء للاستثمار المزيد
في وصف الحلقه
[موسيقى]
طيب انا الحين عندي السؤال مره مهم ابيك
تكون مخفي ممكن تتخلص
السؤال هذا اهم سؤال
يعني برنامج رائع شغل رهيب
بس
الى الان الكلام على الشراكه مع قطاع
الخاص تمكي القطاع الخاص حوافذ قطاع خاص
بس بالضبط وش هي هذه الحوافز ذي عجزت يعني
امسك شيء ملموس او اعرف فلو عندك امثله
للشركات او للحوافز هذه بحيث انه فعلا
يبان انه في شيء خاص لهالشركات عامه او
تنظيمات عامه هم وغيرهم بيستفيدون منها اي
صحيح شوف يمكن انا بستكمل على سؤال الثاني
اللي قلت كيف التواصل بينكم التواصل بيننا
وكيف الشركات تقدم حنا لما تصير شركه
مؤهله ننتقل الى
اليوم الشركه بتعطيني وش المشاريع اللي
عندها الاعتياديه اللي هي ما تستحق ايه
حوافز او دعم لانها بتجي طبيعه الحال فانت
لو تعطيها موارد ما كانت يعني في غير
محلات انت تبغى تحفز اللي هي خارج الخطه
الاستثماريه او الجانب الثاني تسريع وتيره
الاستثمار ان لم تجيك شركه تقول انا ثلاث
مشاريع الى 2030 ممكن استثمرها الى 2026
اذا تعطيني حوافز اسرع من وتيره الاستثمار
وهذا شيء ننظر له فانا يعني يمكن الخطوه
الرئيسيه والتحدي الاكبر لما بدا البرنامج
وكنا حريصين شركات تكون جزء من وش
احتياجاتهم
اساسا يصمم بالطريقه هذه تتناسب مع
الاهداف واحتياجاتهم
وهذه يمكن كانت ايضا فيها تحدي لانه صار
في صوره ذهنيه عند الشركات
هذه الحوافز البرنامج بيعطيني
هالقدر من
المبالغ ولا الدين وانت في النهايه يجب ان
يكون في توازن لانه يعني انت تبغى تعظم
الفائده للطرفين ما بين الحكومه ان تعطي
يعني حوافز تعرف ان العائد حقها عالي وفي
نفس الوقت تبغى ان الشركه تاخذ يعني
حاجتها من هالجانب فاللي حنا نسويه بعدها
تحدد المشاريع واذا صار انه مشروع فعلا
اضافي
تعطينا في نموذج كامل
اقتصاديات المشروع ويعني
كان بيدخل جميع المعلومات اللي نحتاجها
الماليه واحنا من ناحيتنا يمكن عمر اهم
شيء ننظر له المضاعف الاقتصادي انه يكون
في عائد اقتصادي
وهذا العائد لانه نضمن بهالطريقه انه
الاهداف العامه الاقتصاديه تحققت يعني صار
في دوران اكثر مكن يعني توظيف مكنتصدير
محتوى محلي
وفي النهايه هو ايضا يعطينا يحتاجها يقول
انا احتاج واحد اثنين ثلاثه اربعه
ندرسها ونحاول نهي كلها بافضل طريقه اللي
تكون يعني تخدم اهدافه وفي نفس الوقت يعني
تكون
يعني ما تستهلك اكبر قدر من الميزانيه
لانه في اليوم ميزانيه للحوافز والبرنامج
ميزانيه محدده مخصصه للشركات بس اذا تسمح
لي يمكن استطرد قبل يعني
[موسيقى]
الحوافز والكذا الرحله يعني مع الشركات
ويعني
الجاهزيه والتحديات يعني
الموجوده زي ما قلت لك انه الصوره الذهنيه
لما بدات وحاولت احتياجاتكم صارت يعني
عندهم فكره
قد تكون غير متوافقه مع الاهداف انا عندي
ميزانيه محدده عندي اهداف يجب انها
شريك
احنا خلصنا ميزانيه محدده وبدينا فيها
ويمكن صرفنا جزء جيد منها واعتقادي انه
يعني باذن الله على اللي انا قاعد اشوفه
من ناحيتك بعد الشركات واعتقد انه يعني
الاقبال سيزيد
يعني بعد اعلان او يعني من بعد اعلان
المشاريع بيكون فيه اكثر
فيعني مش معلن ما اعلم لكن انت يعني
تشكيل لجنه الحوافز الجوانب هذي كلها
معينه لكن خصص ميزانيه محدده لبرنامج شريك
حلو فانت الان يعني توك كنت تقول على على
جلوسكم معاهم وضبط توقعاتهم وضبط التوقعات
فهذه يمكن كانت الفتره الاولى وانا كنت
حريص عمر من البدايه حتى يعني اللجنه
تبغى تروح للشركه يكون فيه معايير واضحه
تعريفات واضحه يعرف كيف يقدر يشتغل معك
تشتغل معه ولا تتغير الرساله هذه مع الوقت
والحمد لله هذا تحقق يعني في بدايه العامل
الماضي كان عندنا معايير الاهليه واضحه
معايير الحوافز وتقييم المشاريع واضحه وش
الفرق ما بين الاستثمارات الاضافيه
والاستثمارات الاعتياديه هذه كلها فانا
قعدت تقريبا يمكن شهرين ما اتقابل مع يعني
اي شركه لان
ها ابي اروح لما قلت تراني انا اليوم جاهز
وهذه المعايير اللي موجوده
ويعني الجانب الثاني اللي عملنا عليه
تخصيص ميزانيه
انا الان بروح الشركات ترى عندي ميزانيه
مخصصه لكم انتم
اللي عنده القدره
ويعني انه يقدم ويستفيد هو اللي بيستفيد
لانها ما هي مضبوطه انه الشركه الثانيه
بتاخذ كذا ولا بتاخذ كذا ولا معايير واضحه
المؤهل ياخذ وابتر الله يوفقهم اللي يقدر
يعطيني عاده واللي بياخذها لا ما في عاده
انا اتكلم
اللي عنده عادي اقتصادي ويسوي المعايير
بياخذها وفيها اكيد سقف معين طبعا حنا يوم
يعني نظرنا
يعني شفنا زي ما قلت في مقارنات وكذا شفنا
اكبر يعني 500 مشروع العالم دعم وش نسب
الدعم من الاستثمار فعندنا هذه يعني
كمرجعيه او احد الاشياء نرجع لها في من
ناحيه الضوابط وهذا اللي يقول لك اياها
يعني كان احد التحديات يعني انا ما انسى
في يمكن الصيف الماضي
نبغى عندنا مستهدف طموح
لعام 2022
انه نوافقه على 11 مشروع بمبالغ معينه
وكنا ذاك الوقت ما وصلنا ثلاث اربع مشاريع
وعندي مشروعين جاهزين
لكن ما قدرت مع الشركات على الحوافز هم
طالبين
يعني حوافز بالنسبه لنا تعتبر نسبتها من
الاستثمار جدا كبيره وزي ما قلت لك الجانب
الثاني اللي هو مهم بالنسبه للاستدامه
الماليه على المدى البعيد انا لو ما اعطي
حوافز الى مشروع غير مستدام معناته اهدرت
الاموال فمن الضروره الاستدامه
والاستمراريه للمشروع وكم السقف حق
الحوافز مقارنه باجمال استثمار كم السقف
تقول اعلم كذا مو منطقي يعني
يمكن احد الاشياء الثانيه اللي يعني
نستطرد فيها
لما بدا البرنامج كان فيه طبعا حنا يعني
بشكل شهري نجتمع مع اللجنه ومع اسمه سيدي
احد الاشياء الاستراتيجيه انه يوم عندنا
استراتيجيات قطاعيه عند القطاعات مختلفه
عندنا منظومات على مستوى الحكومه اهداف
استثماريه
لا نستطيع نعمل من دون يعني مو بالتنسيق
احنا يبغى يكون دور رئيسي في حوكمه
البرنامج
لانه
مكملين لهم
وهذه كانت يمكن احد الاشياء اللي من
اللجان يعني في الاجتماعات تناقشنا فيها
على توجه هذا توجه استراتيجي مسار مهم
ولما نوقش يعني
دعم بشكل كبير من
سمو الامير والاعضاء لانه ما تقدر تحقق
الهدف الاكبر يجب انه يكون فيه حوكمه
واضحه فكانت الفكره الاساسيه انا عندي
قطاعات عندي
القطاعات بحيث انه يكون
معالي الوزير المعني بالقطاعي راسها
اللجنه عندها هدفين رئيسيه
اليوم انا عندي هدف طموح كيف اقدر احققه
اذا قعدت في المكتب
ما راح اقدر احققه لازم اكون مبادر
فحنا نشوف
نعرض فرص على الشركات مشاريع استراتيجيه
تتوافق مع استراتيجيات القطاعيه ومع
الاهداف الاستراتيجيه فانت على سبيل
المثال لو ناخذ استراتيجيه وطنيه للصناعه
تتطلب استثمارات متقطاع الخاص فوق
التريليون ريال
النقد نفس الشيء فوق الخمسميه مليار
فاليوم كيف اوافق ما بين هذه انا عندي
شركات الكبرى اللي هي عندها القدره واخذ
الاولويات هذه ويعرضها بقالب
يتناسب معهم فكذا سرعنا من هذا الجانب
الجانب الثاني
الجانب التنظيمي ولا حول ولا الاشياء اللي
تمكن
استثمارات لهذه الشركات
فاليوم بشكل ربعي ويكون في تحديات للشركات
تعرض على معالي الوزير المعني ويتم حلها
وفي نفس الوقت
نبدا يعني نعرض الفرص اللي يكون فيها عائد
اقتصادي عالي وتتوافق فنكون مبادرين معنى
السنه شركات تجينا حنا اللي بدينا نبادر
على اساس نسرع من عجله الاستثمار
اسسنا ست لجان كمرحله اولى
ست قطاعات عندنا قطاع الطاقه قطاع الصناعه
قطاع الاتصالات
قطاع النقل وخدمات اللوجسيه قطاع العقار
والبناء والقطاع المالي هذه هي اول ست
قطعات واللي يظهر انها هي ذات اولويه صحيح
والاربعين شركه كلها القطاعات ولا مو
بالضروره او يعني مو بالاغلب
لكن مو بالضروره احنا عندنا ايضا ثلاث
رجال ناويين
نفعلها من النصف الثاني من هذا العام بس
عشان افهم اذا انا مثلا القطاع النقل
تواصلي مع حلجنا اذا كنت من الشركات
الكبرى او اذا كنت من الشركات اللي مقبوله
في البرنامج ولا اي شركه في القطاع مش
علاقه اللجان الفرعيه او القطاعيه
بالشركات الكبرى في القطاع
هي معنيه لان اليوم هدف الخمسه ترليون قسا
على هذه على القطاعات وهدفنا
اننا نصل لمستهدف الخمسه ترليون عن طريق
هذه الشركات اللي موجوده فاحنا نبحث
انضمام شركات اكثر من القطاع نفسها حنا
نعرض فرص استثماريه
الشركات القطاع نعرض تحديات الشركات اللي
في البرنامج من القطاع هذا ونركز على
الجانب الاستثماري يعني اذا كان في هذا
التحدي ترى اذا تم معالجته فيمكن
استثمارات واللي ترى اليوم الشركه متعطله
تستثمر هالمبالغ وعندهم هذا التحدي فيعرض
على هذه اللجان
ولما نرجع للموضوع الحوافز وش نوع الحوافز
اللي قاعده تقدم لها الشركات شوف اليوم
عمر في ثلاث انواع من الحوافز لكن حنا من
ناحيتها البرنامج منفتحين لاكثر لكن
الحوافز اللي تم طلبها في المشاريع هي
تتلخص في ثلاث جوانب الجانب الاول تكون
هبه او جراند
الجانب الثاني يكون دعم في التمويل او في
اسعار الفائده الجانب الثالث يعني اعطاء
ضمان لطلب حكومي معين في مشروع معين وضمان
انه متعهد شراء او او هنا النقطه وهذه
اللي انا اقول لك اياها يمكن فيها قصه
يعني مختلفه في احد المشاريع اللي جاتنا
يعني كانت توصيه بالرفض او يعني عدم
الاكمال لان ما نقدر نعطيهم تعهد شراء حسب
الانظمه
[موسيقى]
يعني حسب النظام
فاللي نظرنا فيه نظرنا بشكل مختلف
قلنا اليوم الشركه تبغى حجم الطلب في هذا
القطاع
يبغون منه مثلا واحد في الميه
فمما لا شك فيه انا عندي اطمئنان انه في
حال الشركه التزمت بضوابط
المناقصات وقدمت يعني اسعار تنافسيه تقدر
تاخذ لكن اعطيتهم اطمئنان في حال التزمت
في جميع الضوابط اللي موجوده
انا اضمن لك هالمبلغ
بعد فتره معينه من يعني من السنوات
فانت تحقق نفس
التعهد لكن
اعطيتهم يلتزمون بالاجراءات حيث تكون
اسعار تنافسيه وفي نفس الوقت اطمان انه
يقبل بالاستثمار ويستثمر هالمبالغ لانه
يدري انه عنده يعني هل اطمئنان اللي جاء
فهي ثلاثه اما هبه ماليه او تسهيلات ماليه
باسعار فائده مدعومه
او ضمانات هل نقدر ناخذ امثله على كل وحده
منهم
انا اعرف بتحب السؤال هذا
اتوقع ببسط الفكره عند المشاهدين
عشان يفهمون ايش نعني بكل نوع من انواع
هذا الدعم الا انا اقول لك يعني لما نجي
وهذا اللي احنا يجي بننظر له يعني لان
الامثله اللي عندنا جدا
يعني مختلفه انت اليوم مثلا الشركات زي ما
قلت لك يعني يكون في تحدي على
المشروع غير مجدي لانه فيه مثلا متطلبات
لاساسيه بنيه تحتيه امور مختلفه
فيحتاج الدعم معين
لتخطي هذا الجانب فهنا من هالجانب يكون
مثلا الهبه ولا من يعني في بناء يعني
بنيه تحتيه معينه
تدعم هذا الجانب
نفس الشيء من ناحيه يعني
تكلفه التمويل ويعني
تغطيه جزء منها برفع اقتصاديات المشروع
وعوائد يعني اعطيك مثال احد الشركات كان
عندهم مشروع لكن ما كان يستوفي الحد
الادنى للعائد الاستثماري مع هذه الحوافز
مكنتهم صار مجدي للاستثمار
وتم يعني ساعه اول مره تكون في المملكه
نفس الشيء يعني احد الاستثمارات الاخرى
كانت الشركه تنظر لها المشروع لخدمه
احتياجها فقط
[موسيقى]
تحتاج لها احتياجات معينه يتطلبها المشروع
لنقل المواد وتصدير المواد الجوانب هذي
كلها
كانت
يعني
جزء من الدعم المقدم
وش اكثر نوع من يعني انتم قدمتو ملح صح لا
صحيح قدم وش اكثر نوع من المنح قدم
نتكلم على ايش نوع البنى التحتيه الاغلبها
كانت ايصال بطاقه ولا نتكلم احنا على
البنيه التحتيه اللي اللي اكثر جزء من
الشركات
يعني في زي ما قلت لك يعني مثلا مشروع لما
اخذناه
كانت بنيه تحتيه
يعني من ناحيه رصيف الميناء
والجوانب المختلفه
هذا جانب في جانب اخر كان في تحديات
المشروع فقدم يعني تحديات تشريعيه
التحديات يعني اقتصاديات المشروع
التسهيل
في مشروع اخر يعني تم تقديم
دعم للانشاءات اساس زي ما قلت لك كان في
عائد معين على اساس انه يعني تستثمر
تقرر شركه قبل الاستثمار وهذه نرجع يعني
النقطه الاساسيه اللي هي انا اتكلمت فيها
انا هذي كلها مشاريع استطاع يعني اضافيه
من دون هذا الدعم ما كانت الشركات بتقدم
يعني على هذه الاستثمارات فاليوم يعني له
الحمد مكنا هذه الاستثمارات كلها لها
عوائد اقتصاديه يعني بتقدر
باثنين فاصله 25
واثرها كبير حتى ما بعد كل الريال يصرف
بالخير برنامج الشريك عائد الاقتصادي كما
متوسط 2.25 صحيح بس على برنامج شريك ايضا
على استثمار الشركه نفسها لا تتذكر ان ترى
الجزء الاكبر من الاستثمار الشركه ستقوم
فيه دعم البرنامج لتقرير المخاطر لتحسين
العائد لمعالجه يعني
جزئيات بسيطه بس البرنامج ما هم مصمم انه
يعطي دعم كبير لتنميه صناعه معينه او بناء
يعني
حنا بالنسبه لنا يعني
نركز على العائد الاقتصادي واستدامه
الماليه للمشروع وانه يكون نبي نعظم
العائد على اكبر قدر من المشاريب اليوم في
صناديق التنمويه
مفترض انها قاعد تعطي قروض او تسهيلات
بفوائد تكاد تكون محدوده يعني فوش ف اللي
انتم بتسوونه عنهم شوف احنا في النهايه
ننظر للمشروع بشكل عام ونحاول يعني
نقلل المخاطر للشركه كيف نقل الخاطر من
الشركه من ناحيه العائد الداخلي بالنسبه
لهم حسب دراستهم بحيث انه يكون مجدي
في النهايه يعني
لما تعطي دعم على سعر الفائده وتثبته مثلا
تقول انا بدعم واحد في الميه من سعر
الفائده على فتره
فتره معينه من السنوات مع مشروع هذه ايه
فانت في النهايه يعني
اثرت على العائد الداخلي وعطيته يعني
القدره لو كان متردد في المشروع ولا كذا
صار عنده اطمئنان اكثر لانه
يعني هذه
بتدعم العائد اللي هو يطلبها ويستهدفه
[موسيقى]
طبعا الانسان بطبعه يبقى يعظم العوائد
يعني بتجينا انا بقول لك 5% بمئتين في
الميه عهد وش اللي يحدها هل هي
القطاعات المماثله عالميا والعوائد القطاع
نفسها ولا حجم المخاطر شلون قبلته هذه
العوائد لهذا المشروع ودعمته الفائده
لتحقيق العوائد
قلت لك يعني الجانب الاول اللي هو ننظر له
العائد الاقتصادي مشروع الثاني نسبه
الحوافز من الاستثمار وهذه اضطررت
[ضحك]
فلذلك يعني
فيعني شويه انا اقلق اذا اذا الموضوع ما
هو مغري للاستثمار الاجنبي فانت فعليا
قاعد تاخذ من اقتصاد وتحط في الاقتصاد فما
بدل ما توزعها ارباح المساهمين اخذتها
وحطيتها في مصنع جديد ولا في توسعه جديده
ليش البرنامج ما هو جاذب للاستثمار اجنبي
شفنا اعتقد يعني البرنامج خصص لشركات
المحليه اهلا زي ما قلتيه وطنيه الاستثمار
استهدف 12.4 ترليون استمارات حتى عام 2030
محليه واجنبيه الشريك هو يمثل 40% خمسه
ترليون لكن الاستثمار الاجنبي مستهدف
تريليون 800 مليار احنا جزء كثير يعني
اليوم زي ما قلت لك التجارب والناجحه
تحتاج توطين صناعه تحتاج مشاريع مشتركه
فاليوم لما يجي ننظر
حتى المشاريع اللي اعلنت في جزء منها
مشروع مشترك مع مستثمر اجنبي فانت وطنت
الصناعه جبت استثمار اجنبي
في نقل المعرفه بتبني يعني
صناعات مختلفه من تحتها الصناعه
والشيء الجيد وهذه معالي وزير استثمار كان
حريص عليها اليوم في مسارين مسار لشركات
اجنبيه ومسار شريك بس نفس المشروع هل من
المنطق انه يعني يتم النظر فيه من جهتين
مختلفه وكان يعني توجه معالي وزير استثمار
حريص على تجربه المستثمر نبي مكان واحد
وكذا كان مشروع مشترك مع الشريك خلاص شريك
يدرس
الحوافذ الحواف السكون للطرفين يعني
طالما انه جزء من المشروع مشترك صحيح لكن
المستثمر الاجنبي مئه في المئه وجاي ما
يستفيد صحيح
هل تشترطون
على الشركات المدعومه انها ما توزع ارباح
لا ما نشر الشركات المدعومه حنا بالنسبه
لنا يعني
قرار توزيع الارباح من عدمه هو قرار
الشركه
وهيكله يعني الشركه هي مسؤوله عنها حنا
اللي نستهدفه حجم استثمارات معين في
للشركه بشكل سنوي وزي ما قلت لك يعني الحد
الادنى اللي حنا حاطينه مليار ريال
ونستهدف نمو
في الاستثمارات الاعتياديه حق الشركات
مقارنه في التاريخيه وايضا استثمارات
اضافيه اللي هي تستحق الحوافز لكن اي شركه
من ناحيه الهيكله عندها ثلاث قنوات اساسيه
تستخدم السيول الحاليه اللي عندها تقترض
بشكل اكبر او تزيد راس مالها بطلب استثمار
اضافي من المساهمين قرارات هذه كلها
الشركه هي اللي تكررها حنا في النهايه
ننظر الى الاستثمارات
ويعني يهمنا الشركات تلتزم
بمتطلبات البرنامج واحتمل ملاحظات على
البرنامج كانت انه برنامج الحكومه لدعم
شركات الحكومه فاغلب الشركات الشركات
حكوميه مئه في المئه او بنسبه عظمى
من بين الشركات اللي اعلنت اليومين هذه وش
في شركات تعتبر قطاع خاص مئه في المئه او
بنسبه عظمى لو نذكر بعض الامثله شوف يعني
عمر حنا عندنا في البرنامج كثير شركات
يعني
مملوك القطاع الخاص بشكل كامل ولا فيها
ايه ملكيه حكومي انا برنامج استثماري اللي
يهمني تكون مساهمه ومدرجه
تستثمر
المليار ريال او اكثر هذه شرطين الاساسيه
مين الملاك تامها تحققت يعني
ما عندي
ادخل امثله من الشركات القطاع الخاص اللي
اخذت هذا الدعم موجود شركات
يعني
يحدث في الحفل عندنا شركه زين عنده شركه
متقدمه هذول كلها شركات
قطع خاص ما فيها ايه ملكيه حكوميه
وهذا يعني بالنسبه لكم ما هو بعنصر تفضيل
بمعنى لانها شركه خاصه بنعطيها حوافز اكبر
الحكومه ولا العكس
احنا بالنسبه لنا برنامج استثماري بحث هل
شركات صندوق العامه غير المدرجه تاخذ دعم
لا
ما الشركات احنا بالنسبه لنا شرط الادراج
اساسي اوكي بس الصندوق كثير
او المشاريع الكبرى ما هي خارج النطاق حنا
يمكن يعني زي ما قلت لك صندوق عنده مستهدف
وحنا يعني البرنامج عنده مستهدف حنا يمكن
اللي نضره الادراج واذا كان الشركه عنده
خطه واضحه للادراج خلال فتره بسيطه نقدر
نبدا العمل معها من التساؤلات المهمه برضو
هنا علاقتكم بصندوق العامه انتوا كبرنامج
شريك
يعني مش علاقه صندوق العامه حتى يحتضن هذا
المشروع ويكون معالم محافظ هو التنفيذيه
وامين اللجنه يعني انا اعتقد لما بدات
يعني
فكره برنامج شريك تم دراستهم قبل مكتب
اداره الاستراتيجيه وبعدين صدر القرار زي
ما قلت ان الصندوق صناعه العامه يحتضن
امانه لا تسمى شركات الكبرى والبرنامج
يمكن الفكره الاساسيه من الاحتضان اللي هو
تقديم الدعم فاليوم صندوق يقدم الدعم
من ناحيه خدمات المسانده تقنيه المعلومات
الامور فتركيزنا حنا كبرنامج او كاداره
على الاعمال الرئيسيه اللي موجوده فهذا
كان ممكن ومسرع بالنسبه لنا يعني التركيز
على الاساسات اللي بالنسبه للبرنامج
والاهداف الرئيسيه وكان ممكن رئيسي لكنه
منفصلين تماما يعني
انا اعت يمكن الاسم شريك يعني يعطي انطباع
للناس الشراكه يعني في الملكيه وهي ليست
ذلك هي شراكه من ناحيه التحفيز من ناحيه
الدعم من ناحيه الاهداف
الاستراتيجيه من ناحيه اهداف الاستثماريه
هذه الشراكه اللي يعني ينظر لها البرنامج
تذكر وزير التجاره
القصبي يعني تعليق في الشرق الاوسط قال
برنامج شريك سيسهل فتح اسواق عالميه جديده
وتعزيز تواجد المنتج السعودي في اكثر من
178 دوله حاليا
ظنيت هذا الدور هيئه التجاره العالميه او
هيئه هيئه التجاره ايش علاقتكم انتم في
الترويج المنتجات الخارجيه يعني معاليه
لما يتكلم على هذا الجانب الشريك يمكن
الصادرات ويمكن الصادرات جديده التي تدخل
الاسواق العالميه فزي ما قلت لك الان لما
تجيب مشاريع كثير جزء منها
يعني لاستخدامه داخليا وجزء لتصدير وهذه
ترجع لنفس التجربه الكوريه اللي كانت يعني
صارت الشركات كانت تركيزها على الجانب
الصادرات اكثر فهو يقدر من هذا الجانب انه
البرنامج
سيدعم مشاريع جزء منها اسرع العائد
الاقتصادي لما تنظر له
محتوى المحلي يكون له دور كبير الصادرات
الدور الثاني فهذا مقصد انه تمكين كثير من
المشاريع اللي يعني تصدر منتجات وتضع
المملكه في موقع ريادي وعلى هذا السياق
اتذكر يمكن من
من الاجابات اللي ما انساها لقاء الامير
محمد مع ترك الدخيل وقت اطلاق الرؤيه قاعد
اتكلم على رياده السعوديه في القطاع
الغذائي وضرب مثال بالمراعي
ومنتجاتها في الاسواق العربيه وفي المنطقه
عندك اليوم
سلاسل مطاعم تميزت جدا مثلا البيك في
السعوديه الحلقه اللي قبلها الحلقه نشرت
كانت مع مع مؤسس الشركه المالكه لعلامه
ماكدونالدز
وعندهم توسع مهول في الفروع عندهم توسع
لكن
الدجاج من خارج السعوديه اللحوم الخارج
السعوديه البطاطس مخارج السعوديه لانه ما
في والسبب في حديثي معك كان يقول انه احنا
عجزنا نبغى نقنع المصانع تجي المصانع
عندها متطلبات معينه عشان تجي مصانع
الدوليه اللي تبيع لنا وتبيع الغيرنا
وتصدر حتى للعالم
فهل قطاعات زي هذه اظن برضو نفس الشيء
البيت يستورد كثير من
الدجاج واللحوم ما عنده لحمه الدجاج من
خارج السعوديه قطاعات زي هذه هل ايضا
مستهدفه في الشريك انها توطن لانها امن
غذائي وايضا جانب استثماري وفيها صادرات
هي شف يعني الشركات اللي تستوفي المعايير
بتكون من ضمنها وعدتك قطاع الزراعه
والاغذيه من اللجان اللي يعني
بنفعلها في النصف الثاني
من الثلاثه الاضافيه فهذا موجود حنا هدفنا
بشكل عام يعني التوطين والمحتوى المحلي
والجوانب هذه لانك انت في النهايه لما
تستوروا
الوارداتك صار في اثر كبير عليك
خلقت وظائف ويعني
وممكن ايضا تصدر من الجوانب هذه
على العكس حركت 28 شركه في شركات غذائيه
صحيح مثل المراعي مثلا جزء من
الشركات اللي في ضمن الحزمه الاولى
يعني من الشركات اللي 28 شركه صحيح
حنا يعني ممكن انه اي شركه مؤهلات تنضم
بشكل مباشر للبرنامج
خلينا نفترض انه انا شركه اكس
درست معاكم شفتوا ارقام الماليه شفتوا
اموري اعطيتوني منحه لبناء هذا الرصيف ولا
هذا الميناء ولا هذا البنيه التحتيه اين
كانت او دعمتوني اسعار الفوائد
استثمرت السنه الاولى
السنه الثانيه اما لعدم اقتناء بالفرصه
لاسباب داخليه في الشركه ولا خلافات
اداريه ما كملنا
فيه اليه استرجاع الحوافز وفيه اجراءات
خطه تصحيحيه تقدمها ويعني
في اجراءات تحمي حقوق
حقوق هذه الحوافز بحيث انك تتاكد انها
استخدمت في المجالس الصحيح وفي حال ما
استخدمت يكون في فرصه تصحيحيه وفي حال
يعني ما تجاوبت الشركه يتم استرداد
الحوافز بس في فرصه تصحيحيه صحيح بالبزنس
بطبيعته مليان مفاجات صحيح احنا يعني اذا
كانت في ظروف خارجه
امور مختلفه يعني زي ما شفنا في الجائحه
يعني لو اي احد كان ملتزم موجات الجائحه
فيتاثر البرنامج
الاستثماري والزمني وهذا اللي حنا حرسنا
عليه انه يكون فيه يعني اليه فيها مرونه
وفي نفس الوقت تحمي
حقوق الدوله
اتذكر فيما قال لعبد الله الرب الكاتب
بالمعروف عبد الردي اول معنى الشريك كتب
مقاله في في ثمانيه
واقتبس منها تقف تحديات عديده امام تحقيق
كل ما ذكر من الاستثمارات شريك وبقيه خطط
التحفيز الاخرى ومن ابرزها جاهزيه وملاءه
القطاع المالي اذ كما هو متوقع سيزداد
الطلب على التسجيلات الائتمانيه والقروض
المصرفيه بشكل كبير جدا مما سيضغط على
سيوله المصارف يعني ما شاء الله كلن يبي
القروض العقاريه قاعدين يسحبون سحب القروض
السياحيه الان بداوا يسحبون مشاريع الكبرى
مشاريع الصندوق الان انتم ايضا جايين
بتحفزون قطاع الخاص اللي بيروح داخل
تسهيلات اكثر
اختبرته جاهزيه
عملاءه القطاع المصرفي صحيح حنا يمكن
عملنا عمل كامل عندنا اللجنه لقد قطاع
المالي
ونظرنا لهذا الجانب ووضعنا خطه مع ممكنات
مختلفه حتى لا تتعطل يعني
لا تتعطل يعني يكون شركات عندها القدره
على الحصول على التمويل وانها يعني تقدر
تحقق المستهدف
البرنامج
قبل ما اختم ودي اعرف هل في لكم اثر على
غير هذا الشركات الكبرى اللي تختمونها ولا
تركيزكم عليهم واثركم عليهم لا شف حنا
يعني
اقتصادي معناته دخلنا في الاقتصاد بشكل
كامل
يعني الشركات المحليه الشركات
المتوسطه والصغيره كلها زي ما قلت لك يعني
العجل الاقتصاديه تعني في ان الجميع
يستفيد لما اي شركه السفر مليار
وعائد اكثر من اثنين معناته دخل قطاعات
مختلفه جاب المقاولين وجاب مواد البناء
وشراء مواد وبعدين
جاب يعني
مهندسين
الصحيح يكون فيها يعني في محتوى محلي حرك
العجله بعدين لما بدا ينتج صار في داخل
حكومي ايضا من
المبيعات شغل
ووظف
انتج صدر
اعطى من هالبضاعه لمصانع اخرى تبني تنتج
يعني
منتجات اخرى فتحركت العجله بشكل كبير
فالفائده تعم بشكل كبير على يعني جميع
القطاعات او جميع الشركات
ولو بختم ابو محمد واسالك بمثال كوريا
وقلت انه البذره اللي بذروها في الستينات
جنى ثمارها اليوم
وانتهت بعد 30 سنه اصلا يعني الكيان اللي
بدا هذه الشراره انتهت التسعينات فانت
اليوم اول رئيس تنفيذي يقود هذا البرنامج
ويبذر بطبيعه الحال مع الفريق هذا البذور
بعد 30 سنه وش تتمنى تحكي لمحمد
ولا هذاك الجيل عن هذا البرنامج والله
شفنا يعني يمكن رؤيتي نظرته 2030 واحنا
يمكن سهل عندك خمسه مليون تبي تحققها
ولا سهل
واضح وليس سهل
واضح وهدف واضح
لكن هدفي الرئيسي في 2030
الكل ترليون وخلال هالرحله وطنا صناعات
يعني
نتيجه فظائف
كبيره زاد المحتوى المحلي قلدت الواردات
لمنتجات كثيره زادت الصادرات صارت الشركات
هذه
تنافسيه على مستوى العالم صارت منتجاتها
في كل مكان هذا الطموح اللي اطمح له وان
شاء الله اننا نقدر يعني
ندعم الشركات وتحقيق هذه الاهداف باذن
الله تعالى شكرا على قبول الدعوه محمد
وبالتوفيق في المساهمه في وصولنا الاكبر
15 اقتصاد في العالم بالذي شاكر لك يا ابو
عبد الرحمن وموفقين ان شاء الله شكرا لكم
شكرا في هذا القصير في اعداد وانتاج
الحلقه عبد الرحمن عطاس وياسر كذا شغل في
الكاميرات في التحرير محمد الديني وفي
الهندسه الصوتيه محمد الحسن وفي الاشراف
على الانتاج رزان هيثم هذا بودكاست
استقراط احد منتجات شركه ثمانيه للنشر
والتوزيع